it's 1878 Sir Francis Galton gives a
remarkable talk he's speaking to the
anthropologic Institute of Great Britain
and Ireland known for his pioneering
work in human intelligence Dalton is a
brilliant polymath he's an explorer an
anthropologist a sociologist a
psychologist and a statistician he's
also a you Genest in this talk he
presents a new technique by which he can
combine photographs and produce
composite portraits this technique could
be used to characterize different types
of people
Galton thinks that if he combines
photographs of violent criminals he will
discover the face of criminality but to
the surprise the composite portrait that
he produces is beautiful gulten
surprising finding raises deep questions
what is beauty why do certain
configurations of lime and color and
form excite us so for most of human
history these questions have been
approached using logic and speculation
but in the last few decades scientists
have addressed the question of beauty
using ideas from evolutionary psychology
and tools of neuroscience we're
beginning to glimpse the why and the how
of beauty at least in terms of what it
means for the human face and form and in
the process we're stumbling upon some
surprises when it comes to seeing beauty
in each other while this decision
certainly subjective for the individual
its sculpted by factors that contributes
to the survival of the group many
experiments have shown that a few basic
parameters contributes to what makes a
face attractive these include averaging
symmetry and the effects of hormones and
let's take each one of these in turn
Galton's finding that composite or
average faces are typically more
attractive than each individual face
that contributes to the average has been
replicated many times this laboratory
finding fits with many people's
intuitions average faces represent the
central tendencies of a group people
with mixed features represent different
populations and presumably harbor
greater genetic diversity and
adaptability to the environment many
people find mixed-race individuals
attractive and inbred families less so
the second factor that contributes to
beauty is symmetry people generally find
symmetric faces more attractive than
asymmetric ones
developmental abnormalities are often
associated with de symmetries and in
plants animals and humans a symmetries
often arise from parasitic infections
symmetry it turns out is also an
indicator of Health in the 1930s a man
named maximilian factor Rohit's
recognized the importance of symmetry
for beauty when he designed the beauty
micrometer with this device he could
measure minor asymmetric flaws which he
could then make up for with products he
solved from his company named
brilliantly after himself Max Factor
which as you know is one of the world's
most famous brands for makeup the third
factor that contributes to facial
attractiveness is the effect of
and here I need to apologize for
confining my comments to heterosexual
norms
but estrogen and testosterone play
important roles in shaping features that
we find attractive estrogen produces
features that signal fertility men
typically find women attractive who have
elements of both youth and maturity a
face that's too baby like might mean
that the girl is not yet fertile so men
find women attractive who have large
eyes full lips and narrow chins as
indicators of youth and high cheekbones
as an indicator of maturity now
testosterone produces features that we
regard as typically masculine these
include heavier brows thinner cheeks and
bigger squared-off jaws but here's a
fascinating irony in many species if
anything testosterone suppresses the
immune system so the idea that
testosterone infused features our
fitness indicator doesn't really make a
whole lot of sense here the logic is
turned on its head instead of a fitness
indicator scientists invoke a handicap
principle the most commonly cited
example of a handicap is the peacocks
tail this beautiful but cumbersome tail
doesn't exactly help the peacock avoid
predators and approach peahens why
should such an extravagant appendage
evolve even Charles Darwin in an 1860
letter to ASA gray wrote that the sight
of the peacocks tail made him physically
ill he couldn't explain it with his
theory of natural selection and out of
this frustration he developed the theory
of sexual selection on this account the
display of the Peacocks tail is about
sexual enticement
and this enticement means that it's more
likely that the peacock will mate and
have offspring now the modern twist on
this display argument is that the
peacock is also advertising its health
to the peahen only especially fit
organisms can afford to divert resources
to maintaining such an extravagant
appendage only especially fit men can
afford the price that testosterone
levies on their immune system and by
analogy think of the fact that only very
rich men can afford to pay more than
$10,000 for a watch as a display of
their financial fitness now many people
hear these kinds of evolutionary claims
and think they mean that we somehow are
unconsciously seeking mates who are
healthy and I think this idea is
probably not right teenagers and young
adults are not exactly known for making
decisions that are predicated on health
concerns but they don't have to be and
let me explain why imagine a population
in which people have three different
kinds of preferences for green for
orange and for red from their point of
view these preferences have nothing to
do with health they just like what they
like but if it were also the case that
these preferences are associated with a
different likelihood of producing
offspring let's in a ratio 3 to 2 to 1
then in the first generation there will
be 3 greens to 2 oranges - 1 red and in
each subsequent generation the
proportion of greens increase so that in
10 generations 98% of this population
has a green preference now a scientists
coming in and sampling this population
discovers the green preferences are
universal so the point about this little
abstract example is that while
preferences for specific physical
features can be arbitrary for the
individual
if those features are heritable and they
are associated with a reproductive
advantage over time they become
universal for the group so what happens
in the brain when we see beautiful
people attractive faces activate parts
of our visual cortex in the back of the
brain an area called the fusiform gyrus
that is especially tuned to processing
phases and an adjacent area called a
lateral occipital complex that is
especially tuned to processing objects
in addition attractive faces activates
parts of our reward and pleasure centers
in the front and deep in the brain these
include areas that have complicated
names like the ventral striatum the or
bur frontal cortex and the ventral
medial prefrontal cortex so our visual
brain that is tuned to processing faces
interacts with our pleasure centers to
underpin the experience of beauty now
amazingly while we all engage with
beauty without our knowledge beauty also
engages us our brains respond to
attractive faces even when we're not
thinking about beauty we conducted an
experiment in which people saw a series
of faces and in one condition they had
to decide if a pair of faces were the
same or a different person even in this
condition attractive faces drove neural
activity robustly in their visual cortex
despite the fact that they were thinking
about a person's identity and not their
beauty
another group similarly found automatic
responses to beauty within our pleasure
centers so taken together these studies
suggest
that our brain automatically responds to
beauty by linking vision and pleasure
these beauty detectors it seems ping
every time we see beauty regardless of
whatever else we might be thinking we
also have a beauty is good stereotype
embedded in the brain within the orbit
frontal cortex there's overlapping
neural activity in response to beauty
and to goodness and this happens even
when people aren't explicitly thinking
about beauty or goodness
our brains seem to reflexively associate
beauty and good and this reflexive
Association may be the biologic trigger
for the many social effects of beauty
attractive people receive all kinds of
advantages in life they're regarded as
more intelligent more trustworthy
they're given higher pay and lesser
punishments even when such judgments are
not warranted these kinds of
observations reveal beauty's ugly side
in my lab we recently found that people
with minor facial anomalies and
disfigurements are regarded as less good
less kind less intelligent less
competent and less hard-working
unfortunately we also have a disfigured
is bad stereotype this stereotype is
probably exploited and magnified by
images in popular media in which facial
disfigurement is often used as a
shorthand to depict someone of
villainous character we need to
understand these kinds of implicit
biases if we are to overcome them and
aim for a society in which we treat
people fairly based on their behavior
and not on the happenstance if their
looks
let me leave you with one final thought
Beauty is a work in progress the so
called Universal attributes of beauty
were selected for during the almost two
million years of the Pleistocene Life
was nasty brutish in a very long time
ago the selection criteria for
reproductive success from that time
don't really apply today for example
death by parasite is not one of the top
ways that people die at least not in the
technologically developed world from
antibiotics to surgery birth control pin
vitro fertilization the filters for
reproductive success are being relaxed
and under these relaxed conditions
prescence and trade combinations are
free to drift and become more variable
even as we are profoundly affecting our
environment modern medicine and
technological innovation is profoundly
affecting the very essence of what it
means to look beautiful the universal
nature of beauty is changing even as
we're changing the universe thank you
[Applause]